in this film it's not like he's the  Peter you might have expected he is  frightened and yet you have to feel the  beginning of that books but you have to  feel the beginning of joy the  mischievous cheeky playful Peter Pan  that we know how much you want to bet  she's one of the rations for we squeeze  like an elephant's bomb lock onto while  many of us may have grown up reading  with Peters imagination or watching him  fly on the big screen so maybe  unfamiliar with his story to bring his  adventures to a new set of admirers it  was clear that the perfect Peter had to  be sought out  we had casting directors out in every  english-speaking country in the world  looking for our Peter and we must have  seen thousands and thousands of kids and  that Levi just has this kind of light in  his eyes and a kind of wonder that  seemed to the right quality for Peter  and that you like